he's welcome please join me in welcoming
Barbara gross thanks very much for that
wonderful introduction it's really a
great ok it's really a great honor to be
here giving a keynote at a faculty
summit where the theme is is focused on
an AI at the edge it's a time where it's
really important for those of us doing
research in AI to think about what
capabilities systems have what our
methods can do what they can't do
where the challenges are and and what we
may be doing in the future and for
everyone in computer science to think
about how we can design systems that
actually do good in the world and don't
do harm this is perhaps this is Turing's
best-known conjecture about building
machines with intelligence and by the
way he equated intelligence with
thinking he thought they were he wasn't
trying talking about intelligence as
being able to do research that gets a
Nobel Prize
so his most well-known conjectures are
about what he called being able to
participate well in the imitation game
now talked about his passing the Turing
test that conjecture that we would have
machines able to do that by the year
2000 was not realized but the conjecture
that you see on this slide was people
now regularly talk about machines as
though they were thinking of course they
frequently also ask what were they
thinking when they do things that don't
make sense so about five years ago when
we were celebrating the hundredth
anniversary of Turing's birth I was
asked to give a talk at a Turing
symposium and I was trying to figure out
what I could say that was novel because
people have talked about Turing and
written about Turing and I decided it
would be interesting to think about if
Turing were with us now I mean there are
people who live to a hundred years if he
were with us now
what would he be adjust to the people
watching the clock this clock is wrong I
have more than I am not four minutes
over so you might want to reset it okay
they didn't hear me I'll try to keep to
my time without the clock okay so and I
of course no one knows what Turing would
say I got it but I thought the world had
changed a lot and I wanted to put a
challenge to the AI community I hope
that other people would also do that so
I still welcome other challenges and
this is the challenge that I came up
with and it's really important to notice
that this is about working as a team
member over the long term not one-shot
deals not just one question one answer
we can do that just fine and I also want
to say I wanna I it says here that you
won't notice that it's not human it's
not to say that the systems would be
indistinguishable from humans it's fine
to know you're working with a computer
system but it has to behave sensibly so
I'll give you an example from health
care a smart partner that searches
documents much faster than any human
being could do if it delivers sensible
results passes the test if it delivers
nonsense it doesn't okay why now because
AI has really made it out into the world
this focus in this meeting the
descriptions of focus of the summit all
make it very very clear that we now have
AI capabilities entering daily life so
we really ought to think about how the
systems we're building are going to work
with people
another thing that's happened as AI
technologies have made it into the world
we see widespread investments in AI we
see lots of claims about them we see
lots of fantasies not only that you can
let your car drive well you play games
or watch movies don't do it
we're not there yet but also in health
care in elder care in education and it
is crucial as we think about this to
think not simply about the systems but
about the people that they interact with
and of course we also have a lot of
nightmares I will say the nightmares are
not new people have been thinking about
building machines could a human being
build a machine create something that
could think that was like a person for
centuries goes back at least to the
Golem of Prague certainly to
Frankenstein and more recently we have
things like the movie ex machina so on
the one hand this Android dream set a
context for Touring's conjecture on the
other hand it makes clear that there has
at least in Western culture it's very
different in Japan by the way they think
of robots as cuddly but at Eastern and
I'll leave it as a as a question for you
to think about the cultural part so my
argument is if we want to get away from
the philosophical focus and Turing was
asking a philosophical question and away
from the science-fiction of machines
gone mad to get real intelligent
behavior we need to think about building
machines that augment our capabilities
not that replace us or replicate human
intelligence so here's my quip we know
how to replicate human intelligence the
process is known to be fun the product
is babies even when they grow up they
have only human intelligence we we don't
need to build machines that have more of
that we need to build machines that
complement that and I'm going to very
quickly talk about five reasons why we
want to aim for coordination and
teamwork now the first two are about how
times have changed since stirring then
about our responsibilities and then
because we're doing research we want to
do exciting research so that's how
people use computers in turing today one
person one machine now we have many
people in many places and many systems
working at many
there are several arguments from the
cognitive sciences also just say a
couple briefly brain development we know
that in the first two years of life if
you don't have social interaction your
brain is smaller and it generates less
energy and you're basically cooked for
life if you don't have that social
interaction in time we also know that
language learning depends on
interpersonal interaction there there's
some wonderful work by Patricia Kuhl at
the University of Washington I'll give
you one example she looked at babies
American babies no exposure to any to
Mandarin taking looking at the issue
that was so we're all born for those who
don't know we're all born able to
recognize the phonemes of all languages
in the world by the time we're twelve
months old we know only the phonemes of
the languages that we've been exposed to
in those first twelve months somewhere
between eight and ten months of age
English speaking babies understand the
difference between LNR and Japanese
speaking babies have lost that
distinction many other examples she
compared exposing babies between eight
and ten months
to American babies to a speaker of
Mandarin face-to-face and watching that
same person on video the Mandarin
phonemes were retained by the babies who
had the face-to-face interaction not by
the ones watching the video
okay what about engineering well if we
want to build good systems we have to
think about for people that we're
building systems for and how they use
their how their different cognitive
processes work I'll come back to
language later in the talk but here's an
example to illustrate getting things
wrong I asked my phone's phone I won't
say which one where's the nearest gas
station I got a list of sixteen I asked
which ones were open and it offered to
search the web for the phrase which ones
are open which would have not have
gotten me the answer I wanted
okay I think it's really important for
all of us building systems to focus on
the errors the systems make rather than
bragging about the great successes that
they have because the errors are telling
us where there's a mismatch with our
expectations the same thing is true of
Watson jeopardy and I hear that it's now
proving true of deep learning systems
with captioning of images so look for
the errors to understand where there's a
mismatch finally there's an ethical
argument for considering working with
people autonomous vehicles give a lot of
promise for their the potential is huge
I'm very excited about them but they
have to be able to work with us
otherwise they're gonna run into trouble
and we've already seen many examples of
that as wonderful as the cars are
because we don't do what they expect but
hey we're here first we're building them
for us people are a pain in the neck
anybody how many people here have tried
to do experiments with people really we
don't behave very well but too bad you
got to deal with them and finally there
are all of these really wonderful
scientific challenges so let's go for it
I've listed some here there are many
many more the last one is actually about
the challenge of designing experiments
that let us know how people work okay so
I want to shift now from the argument
for thinking about this to thinking
about the research there are many
domains in which the this challenge
arises many times of teamwork I'm going
to mention those and then I'm going to
talk about some of my own work in
developing foundations theoretical
foundations for modeling team working
and putting those to use so education
healthcare writing papers driving we can
think about groups of people and groups
of systems groups of people that systems
help the last two on this slide
autonomous
human collaborations and crowd work
present really interesting challenges
where we as people can teach machines to
do better but we have to design them so
that they'll learn from us and so that
we're teaching them things that are
interesting not making up not doing
boring things because they are stupid
okay so shift to talking about some some
work there are several different
theories of collaboration that have been
developed I'm going to talk about mine
[Music]
because it has some features I think are
really important but all of them have
most of the features that I'm going to
talk about so the first thing to note
about building systems that can be team
members is you have to design the
teamwork from the start and you'll see
that in the formalism that I show you
and it's partly because whoops
teamwork is not simply the sum of
individual plans
you can't take my plan to do something
and Eric's plan to do something
individually and just smush them
together and you'll see that now in the
theory that I'm going to talk about so
I'm gonna this is all in English it was
actually developed as a formal theory in
logic I'm going to talk about this as I
give you these principles I want you to
understand this is not just soft blah
blah blah but in fact any one of these
principles doesn't hold for a system you
can show it will fail at teamwork at
some point in time so first we need each
team member to commit to the team doing
its job the commitment is as is framed
as an intention which means you have to
believe that the team can actually do
the work you have to reach consensus on
how you're gonna go about doing it and
on who you're gonna allocate subtasks to
now that doesn't mean that everybody in
fact it importantly doesn't mean that
everybody has to know everything about
what every
one else is doing but you need to know
about the points of join so not all the
details just with this much you can see
that there's a requirement that the
group have some decision-making
processes they know when they've come to
an agreement and that they have mutual
belief of the decisions that they have
so we all have to know what we're all
doing in addition to things that I'm
going to illustrate in with some
examples of research are that we have to
commit to the tasks that we're given and
again that commitment is an intention
and you can't commit to something you
can't do that you know you can't do so
our systems cannot commit to doing
things they can't do
you also have to commit to each other's
success which means that you have to try
to the systems have to be able to when
they act to think about whether they are
helping us get our jobs done or
interfering okay so that's the
delegation challenges we're going to
talk about three different roles for
these theoretical frameworks first
system specification then design guide
and then is an analytic framework and I
hope that you'll take away from this
that not only are these roles but each
for each of these roles there are
different ways you could implement the
system so you could use machine learning
or Bayesian reasoning or gritting theory
or logical rules
it's the properties that the theory says
the system has to have that you need to
get into the system within whatever
implementation you're going to use we're
gonna read you a quote from your show um
in a recent CA cm article when he was
talking about the usefulness of logical
logically solid theories he said this
matters because it helps you build
software that's beautiful on the inside
and if the internal structure isn't
right if it doesn't Co here without
humans think of the world you'll never
have a truly beautiful user experience
so I hope you'll keep that in mind
okay so first theory is system
specification and I'm going to talk
about the problem of interruption
management so the shared plan principle
here is that you have to commit to each
other's success so if you're going to
interrupt somebody you ought to have
information that's valuable to them to
interrupt only when it's useful how many
of you have been interrupted by dialog
boxes warning of you of things like your
battery dying in three hours that you
don't really care about now okay so just
go forward without me there we go so
there are two insights that we had about
the interruption management problem and
these are really these are insights from
Ajay Kumar's PhD dissertation work Ajay
is here now the first of these is that
when we're collaborating most of the
time most of what we're doing is
individual remember we break the tasks
down into subtasks we delegate to other
people and if we take advantage of that
New York composability we can get
computational savings the second insight
is that we have to have efficient ways
of reasoning about each other's
activities even when we don't know in
detail what other people are doing so
let me look at the first this is work on
seeing that the problem can decompose
into individual actions and joint
actions and then actually designed a
formalism which he called nearly
decomposable MDPs the idea is you're
maximizing a joint function you have but
you have independent individual and
joint action sets and you decouple the
transitions depending on whether there's
a dependency when you need to
communicate or there's things are
independent the result of this is that
you get exponential efficiencies in
computation time you can actually
compute things you couldn't compute if
you try to do it fully as a fully
coordinated system
okay second the second problem oops
it's running ahead of me oh I have this
fear it's on automatic advance okay so
that's that's an example where there's a
specification that you commit to each
other's success and that you and then
the and therefore that you don't
interrupt when you don't have something
useful the second example I want to use
is work on what we've called
collaborative interfaces and this is in
an educational setting here the domain
challenge is we have lots of interesting
exploratory software for kids in schools
to learn math and science and evidence
shows that by exploring on their own
they learn more than just being lectured
at the constraint that we get from
shared plans and designing these
interfaces is that you can't assign
something to the computer system that it
isn't capable of doing so the task
allocation so we looked at could we
build interfaces that would help
teachers where we leave with the
teachers the things that they do best
so having broad knowledge of students
and how to interact with them but
assigned to the computer recognizing
patterns and what this is what the
students are doing and I'll give you two
examples of this on the left you see
exploratory some exploratory system for
teaching middle school students
probability and statistics so what
happens with you flip a coin and on the
right you see a system for teaching
freshman chemistry what we did in this
work was to expand on plan recognition
algorithms the plan recognition
algorithms that have been developed in
AI up to this point we're all algorithms
that assumed that we were well behaved
eighth grade children give an
exploratory software and not only make
mistakes sometimes that's part of it so
you have to look for things that are not
right and don't fit but they also like
playing around and exploring in ways
that maybe the designers of the system
or the designers of the problems hadn't
thought so the plan recognition
algorithm had to deal with those kinds
of errant behaviors and the result was
that we developed new plan recognition
algorithms so this is a place we're
taking on the challenge of building
something that worked well with people
we actually came up with hard scientific
problems these systems were both
validated offline by through surveys of
teachers and and finding out how well
they worked and also proving correctness
of algorithms one of the most
interesting responses for me happened a
few after after the summit a few years
ago there was a workshop on AI and
education and the chemistry faculty
member at CMU who had developed virtual
labs said the interesting thing for him
was that he learned from the system how
his students were solving problems and
it wasn't the way he thought they were
so this is part of what a system can do
to really help in education but notice
we're not replacing the teacher
we're complementing the teacher more
recently Coby gal who's at ben-gurion
University who worked on s caste and
then did virtual labs has been working
and so this was plan recognition in a
very different domain teaching seventh
grade geometry where the students are
working in small groups and they're
chatting with each other again the
teacher can't listen in on all the
conversations and the technical question
was could you develop could you detect
critical moments in those student
conversations and alert the teacher to
groups that needed to be encouraged to
do something else can't do full natural
language processing of the it's not that
it's not just dialogue it's multiple
students talking at what it wants but
they could use machine learning to
detect those critical those critical
moments and they've just done some early
class
from validations that show that when you
that using the software the teachers are
actually in a intervening at better
moments and the duration of the
interventions is more appropriate for
what they are because they're not trying
to do too many things at once okay
so the third thing that I want to look
at this is my current research on health
care coordination and this is where we
use shared plans not for system design
at least not yet and and not in its
system specification way but to look at
what was going wrong in health care
coordination so the setting is clinics
for children with complex conditions
this could be from genetic problems it
could be from birth problems it could be
from illness at an early age the
children see somewhere between 10 and 15
care providers no human being can keep
track of 14 other people some of us try
but it's really not possible
so the domain challenge here is could we
build a computer system that would
assist the care providers in keeping
track of what each other is doing I'll
just make a note that electronic health
records do nothing to help with this
problem they may exacerbate it and I'll
give you an example in a minute so this
this little sketch just shows you how
much communication goes on in different
modalities among people on a typical
team you can feel very sorry for the PCP
in the middle who is like the quarter
pack and worse with no with no
technology to help it okay what what we
learned from looking at the work that
people were doing was that this was a
very different kind of teamwork from the
tightly coupled teamwork we had studied
before and that our theories had
originally covered and that our plan
Rick
algorithms were working in so the first
thing is the team is relatively flat the
PCP might be in the middle of things but
he's not in charge and he can't dictate
to other people what to do
they're also loosely coupled which is
means that they're like the nearly
decoupled plans sorry I am NOT pushing
the button it's just working its
autonomous I don't know how it became
it's not collaborating well with me I'm
not there yet and I'm not running out of
time yet okay so the bottom line here is
this is where this we have a new kind of
teamwork what we did before will not
work so the first thing we did having
observed this by looking at what people
the care providers are doing by talking
to oh wait I forgot this really great
quote I saw you have to go back to this
because it shows you what one of the
things that me or the graduate student
working on this learned from ask the
physicians that she interviewed was was
there ever a time that they couldn't
find the information they needed in the
electronic health record here's my
favorite example answer there isn't an
example when I wasn't missing
information and the parent the parents
say we need to relay information back
and forth so the parents who aren't
medical experts are trying to figure out
what's important to tell people we
wanted to see if the system could help
with that so here's what shared plans
would tell you about this setting first
if they're going to reach consensus on
the recipe then we could provide support
for people not just making up a care
plan on a piece of paper that they put
in a drawer or the electronic equivalent
but something that's dynamic and active
that in fact takes into account that as
the child's condition changes the plans
evolve we could support communication
and coordination at the appropriate
levels so figuring out who needs to know
what win
in order to do this we have to solve a
really hard information-sharing
challenge which is to figure out who
needs to know what when you don't have
the complete plan information so not
only don't you you know it's not only
that you don't know exactly what
somebody else is doing so the PCP
doesn't know exactly what the GI doctor
is doing nor does the physical therapist
but you may not even know the full set
of plants you may not even have the
probabilistic recipe tree with a
probability over them okay so what Oprah
did was to look at this loosely coupled
nature and recognize that it was
complemented by the extended duration of
the work that people were doing so it's
not one-shot deals and you can take
advantage of that to learn collaboration
patterns over time and from those
collaboration patterns you can you can
learn about task dependencies and task
allocation and you can reason about
information sharing
based on those learned collaboration
patterns well this need is not only in
healthcare but also in various kinds of
office work for example when we write
papers with each other how many of you
when you're writing papers with three or
four other people are sending email and
making phone calls and getting together
right as wonderful as track changes is
in Google Docs so what she did was to
implement this implement the mutual
influence potential representation in
the MIT DOI algorithm for collaborative
writing compared giving all changes
which is what systems today do with
randomly filtering out some so you have
a smaller load with personalized
filtering based on the met DOI algorithm
the results very briefly were that not
surprisingly if you limit the number of
the number of edits you show people
they're more productive because they're
looking at fewer things
if you base the change so this is what's
important about the algorithm if you
base if you base the change on what
you've detected about interactions but
between the work that people are doing
then you get then it's judged more
helpful by the writers and independently
the results are judged higher-quality by
people looking at what comes out so so
this personalized change awareness makes
a difference I'll just note here that
this is this work was really a wonderful
blend of AI and HCI and I think we're at
a time in the development of both fields
where it's crucial for them to work
together they split apart a long time
ago and it's really important to come
together so now I want to take a step
back and actually look at some of the
lessons from the research that I've done
over many decades and as a way of just
summarizing where we are with respect to
this collaborative work and also leading
into some discussion of dialogues
because there's so much going on in the
dialogue and language world these days
so the first thing so I actually got
into collaboration by doing research on
dialogue the first thing was that we
noticed that dialogue
dialogues aren't linear sequences they
aren't random collections they're
actually structured and you'll see an
example in a minute and the language
that we speak indicates the boundaries
and indicates discourse information at
the root of this structuring of language
is the intentions the purposes of the
people having the conversation and this
is maybe the most important lesson for
those of you who are working on dialogue
systems it's not just the streams of
words it's the underlying purposes you
need to understand to really participate
in a dialogue okay we then moved in
trying to candy Seidner and I and trying
to move from
understanding this to understanding how
to model those intentions and that's
when I became interested in
collaboration because you can't
represent intentional structure as plans
of individual agents you have to and
that's where shared plans came from and
then there was a lot of we did it for
dialogue and then mathematician friend
of mine said to me come on to do n it
turns out and it's a lot as any
basketball coach will tell you and it's
a lot harder than - I think there's a
big challenge here at the edge already
with this work which is how to integrate
the principles from shared plans for
dialogue and collaboration in a way that
melds with the data-driven ml approaches
how are you we going to bring these two
together finally from the collaboration
to loosely coupled plans I told you
about that research there is here also a
challenge which is how do we deal a
broader challenge how do we deal with
all the different kinds of teamwork and
coordination which have widely different
information sharing circumstances and
now before I move on to the next thing I
want to talk about which is the ethics
aspect of all of this I want to read a
quote from Zack kahani who is very very
active in health informatics and a big
advocate of using AI to understand and
and support diagnosis he has a mother
who has a cardiac issue and he was
interviewed about this he said that on
the one hand it's really great to
collect data and use AI for that on the
other hand there are family and friends
and here's the quote AI may be good at
chess and go and at developing expertise
once reserved for doctors in arcane
areas such as reading x-rays
radiologists might disagree about it
being our
anyway but AI does not do well at
understanding the wide world of picking
up mood or subtle signs of distress at
convincing a resistant human to listen
to the doctor we don't need a nag for
that we need a caring village so again
an argument for the complementarity of
AI building systems that complement us
rather than thinking about systems that
replace us or simply replicate us so now
I want to turn to look at the question
of ethics and I'm going to do that via
an example of a child's toy and dialogue
because as I said in the beginning AI is
out there in the world where are using
it all the time on phones and for search
and in many other ways and it's even now
entering toys for children and I think
that really highlights the importance of
anyone building a system with any AI in
it frankly I think anyone building a
computer system that people are going to
use for anything other than programming
need to take into account so this is the
for those of you who didn't see this
article in the fall of 2015
Mattel announced a new Barbie doll that
could talk and Mattel advertised it is
your daughter's new best friend here's
an example dialogue taken from the New
York Times I have I teach a course on
intelligent systems design and ethical
challenges and the students in the
course bought a Barbie doll and found
the 300 pages of scripts at the Barbie
doll follows so there are many more
examples that are even worse than this
but we'll deal with this so Barbie knows
this kid has a sister and asked what
does she do what what nice things does
she do for you the child says nothing
Barbie says what's the last nice thing
okay Barbie hasn't understood the word
nothing not in the script it's this
little word negatives are hard anyone
who's
natural-language knows that okay the
child tries to answer but it's got
another kind of negative word destroyed
it Barbie says oh yeah I tell me more
the kid gets a little annoyed I left
that part out more than a little annoyed
and Barbie says have you told your
sister lately how cool she is this point
I believe the child said that's it
Barbie I forgot that part okay so here's
the thing this is not just awkward but
it raised I mean this is kind of funny
for us but the whole idea of having
these kinds of interchanges with a kid
raises some ethical concerns and I'm
just going to talk about two of them or
many more and that one is expectations
that are violated with respect to
dialogue behavior and the fact that this
doll is as my philosophy student page D
said philosophy PhD student teaching
fellow said unremittingly Pleasant like
no human being I've ever met
kind of this emotional equivalent of
being too skinny
okay so language learning the dolls
designed for three to eight year old
children they're supposed to be learning
language and how we have carry on
dialogues what they're learning is you
just ignore what the other person says
and go along with what you're saying
this is not exactly what we would like
to teach three to eight-year-old
children boys or girls
okay how about child development and
friendship so unremittingly pleasant how
many of you are unremittingly pleasant I
didn't think so thank you for being
honest
I don't you know we don't want a
three-year-old to think she has to be
unremittingly pleasant on the other hand
we do want a child to know that there's
the penalty to pay if you're mean to
somebody and Barbie doesn't care what
the child says it just goes along with
its script I'll just make a note here
that I have some worries about anybody
who thinks we should create the
west-world environment given that we
most of us would stop somebody beating a
dog on the street
why didn't we want to teach people that
it's okay to do what goes on in
Westworld I don't know anyway all right
so there are other questions questions
about trust and creativity but I won't
be able to go into those okay you can
ask me about them later okay so it's not
just Barbie it's any approach to
dialogue that misses some of the key
facts we know about human dialogue and
one of those is that dialogues are
structured by purpose they're not just
linear sequences so here's one of my
favorite examples of why that matters
most of us were taught that a pronoun
referred to the last thing that it
matched in number and gender the last
thing that them in blue matches is
number and gender is kids how many of
you think that what this person means is
they put the kids away how many you I
just have to see if you can raise your
hands how many of you think it's
something else
okay so here's what actually went on in
this dialogue there was some intonation
John came by and left the grocery
stopped at you kids and I put them away
after he left there's no question you
didn't have a question about what's
going on now
this is a narrative about groceries I
have to say I was in the airport on
Saturday my plane looked like it would
be canceled I called the MS our travel
people I could have had exactly the same
conversation but with being about Travel
interrupted by saying something to the
noisy kids who are unhappy their plane
might be handsome okay so finally dialog
is not just adjacency pairs its Twitter
conversations aside but you know if they
have their limitations it's not just
question response pairs so just from
looking at this you can see some of the
challenges for chat BOTS open domains
are going to be harder than closed
domains because you have to deal with
many more kinds of purposes short
dialogs that look just like
question-answer pairs are much easier
than when you get into real dialogue
okay what are the roots of the ethical
challenges here well we already saw
missing dialogue capabilities it's also
the case that if you give people
something they have a tent if they if
they think a system can do one thing
they will generalize to us being able to
do another so the last time I asked my
phone where the nearest ER was and I do
this I write gave a bunch of talks for
Phi Beta Kappa traveling around the
country it always could tell me where
the nearest ER was when I asked where I
can get a flu shot it understood what I
said cuz that's what it sent but this is
answer gave me actually two different
answers I don't know why I can't figure
this out more importantly when I asked
where can I go to get a sprained ankle
treated this is the answer I got now
it's not so bad really to tell me how to
treat the sprained ankle but it would
have been really bad if this had been
about a heart attack
okay so so we need to get it right we
need to be clear about what the
competence is and what it's not
and we need to take seriously this idea
that we can't build systems that commit
to doing something they're not capable
of doing but there are many other
ethical challenges that come up and they
affect us not just as individuals but
they can affect whole communities they
can affect the world at large and I have
just some of them here that I hope
people will think about privacy and
security is always brought up but
there's also a place where there's a
clash of the incentives for business and
social good and I'm really glad to see
things like the ether effort here at
Microsoft and the partnership for AI
because it's really crucial that
companies think about this so we saw
this clash in in the concern for getting
more clicks and selling more ads in the
spread of fake news there are also
questions of justice and Eric brought up
some of this and his talk about bias if
you're predicting the future based on
the past at the same time that you're
trying to change communities and lower
crime for example then there is a clash
between this progressive cultural change
you want in the predictions that you're
making also and this this came up in a
State Department workshop I chaired last
fall there's great concern about who
owns the data and here we have data is
not just Google and Facebook by the way
it's the cars that people are driving
who owns that data how is it going to be
shared
who's going to determine what
regulations there are and then there are
questions of equality and making sure
that the benefits of the AI systems we
develop are are spread around the world
and of building trust well there's a
much longer list the second thing I want
to say is that
when you think about AI and ethics we
should think not only about not doing
harm which is really important but about
doing good and there was recently a
triple AI spring symposium in which
people talked about many many different
areas including health care including
sustainability I was glad to learn that
MSR has an effort on AI for Earth and so
I think we really could all be thinking
about there's just many many aspects of
life where we could be building systems
that would be doing good and not just
worried about what we shouldn't be
building ok so then one of the issues
that people think about a lot and I
think we as AI people should think about
as computer scientists by the way this I
don't think this is just an AI problem
it's a problem of all the technology
that we're building is the bad jobs and
about whether we're replacing people
augmenting people or complimenting
people so let me just give an example
from the legal and policy arena where we
can think about things that already
computers are really great at like
document retrieval and search things
that they can do adequately and well
enough in some in some areas like
drafting straightforward documents and
things that at least in the near-term
future they're unlikely to do well like
producing a new persuasive foreign
policy initiative so that's the law
environment the policy environment
health care is similarly nuanced as is
education so the idea that we're going
to replace doctors rather than thinking
about how we can replace them to save
money
we could think about how to build
systems that will let there do that
enable them to do their jobs more
effectively just as we were doing in
with the teachers and the examples I
gave you okay so these are all
high-level things I think there's some
things that as AI people as technology
people as computer scientists we should
be thinking about right now because
these are things we can directly control
we can't control foreign policy and
that's the question of the jobs now not
just in the future and here I've just
given you two examples one is
crowdsource piecework okay so people
working under what conditions who
regulates those conditions and how the
second thing is as we think about
designing systems that have some AI
capabilities we could think about and we
would think about them as complimenting
people rather than mostly replacing
people and when they are they can't do
it they just fail and then some but some
poor person has to take over and make up
for their failures which happens to me
all the time when I get an automated
customer care agent we might think about
figuring out a way to build a system
that would help let's say those customer
care agents do their jobs better so I
would like people to think about that
because I think we can do better than we
have done so far so far we thought about
how could we replace the person okay if
it fails it goes to the person that
makes the person's job one of handling
trying to figure out what the other
person really the person who called in
really wanted it how to make them happy
now that they're extremely unhappy
rather than unable a person to establish
a relationship with somebody and then
get them an answer more quickly so let
me turn to some general ethical
principles people have asked about who
should decide the values and I think
that's a really important thing to leave
with people not machines I also want to
urge people to stop thinking about and
help those of us who are already working
with the press and others to get them to
stop thinking about robots taking over
because it's not happening anytime soon
and it's a distraction from issues that
are important now so I personally think
we
more to fear from dumb systems that
somebody has told us are smart than from
intelligent systems that know their
limits and I know that Eric talked
earlier about unknowns and known
unknowns I think this is really a system
a really important thing to aim for is a
system that knows its limits so there
are different ways for handling the
ethical challenges that come up the one
we hear about most is regulation and
policy
there's also design we can design the
systems differently and that's really
the main message I want people to take
away from here so we can design systems
differently one of the things that many
people are thinking about is could we
build in ethical reasoning capabilities
and that would be great but it's hard
enough to build in reasoning
capabilities so I think this is a
long-term aspiration certainly an
interesting research area but I'd like
to see us focus on design right now
and finally when we put systems out in
the world we could accurately describe
their capabilities Mattel should not
have said the Barbie doll was going to
be your daughter's next best friend okay
so I'm actually unclear whether this is
my time or the total time yeah okay okay
all right okay all right so let me this
is my last major point I said earlier
the teamwork capabilities had to be
designed in from the start
ethics also has to be designed in from
the start and to get it right in the
future we need to do two things one is
those of us who teach need to integrate
ethics into our curriculum we're doing
this at Harvard now we experimented this
past spring with having a small ethics
module in four courses we're going to do
six in the in the fall a quick example
from my class
they study the Facebook emotion
contagion experiment on a Tuesday lots
of discussion of ethics by the way these
students 150 students applied for a
class of 30 so they really wanted to get
in and they cared about ethics
forty-eight hours later on Thursday I
gave an assignment on I did an in-class
activity on designing a recommender
system including needing to list the
characteristics of the users they would
collect after they reported out I asked
how many of them had thought about the
ethical consequences of what they were
the information they were collecting
none of them none well actually this
year won last year none if we're focused
on efficient effective design with all
the stuff you know efficient code etc
etc and ethics isn't on the list it
ain't gonna happen
so that's the second part companies
building systems need to make ethics
part of the product design okay I will
end by saying it's not smart if it
doesn't work with us and we want it
pulling together not pulling against us
I want systems that make us feel smarter
not dumber and conjectures are really
important anybody whose early stage and
wants to know how Chomsky McCarthy
discouraged me can ask me later they
told me what I was doing was impossible
or useless and when we first did shared
plans people told us to think harder and
we could do it as individual plans so if
you're young and you have a good idea go
with it we need people to take risks now
computers aren't Islands we got to do
this these are all the people that
helped me including the funders and I'm
happy for questions
Thank You Barbara we have time for a few
questions there are people running
around with paddles so if you have a
question please raise your hand and
please say who you are and where you're
from
hi Wrentham from UC Berkeley wait wait
where are you I didn't even call on
anyone yet okay
paddle three hi Renan from UC Berkeley
thanks for the wonderful talk I had a
question about foundations for teamwork
mm-hmm
you talked about how you're designing it
from the start is really critical for
success how do these other higher-order
social activities build into that
foundations with the sort of the the
status today things like competition
justice you mentioned ethics a little
bit how does that factor in well that's
what for people here and their students
and postdocs to start working on number
one over there you think we should be
educating these students understanding
and starting to deal with some of the
ethical issues they are describing
that's terrific and I can tell you best
by telling you a bit about my course
which is that it's aimed at students who
have had one programming course I co
teach it with somebody who is either a
philosophy graduate student or a next
coming year actually a philosophy
faculty member I think it's really
really important to have somebody who
has deep expertise and ethics there with
you almost and let me tell you about
what we did at Harvard in the spring we
had a recent PhD in ethics
with faculty to talk about the systems
the courses and what they were teaching
and then find a particular example where
ethics mattered so for example in the
HCI class they they looked at
accessibility many apps are not
accessible to people who were blind or
deaf so they that was an issue that they
talked about
needless to say in social networking
they talked about fake news so you can
find I would that's what I would
recommend find there there gotta be a
lot of good people or philosophers in
Britain who have studied ethics in fact
the trolley problem comes out of written
by the way and really so make it an
integrated part of the design that
they're doing in the projects that
they're working on but bring it so I am
Anna I'm a disbeliever in professional
ethics I think that's if you follow
these rules you won't get sued you
really really have to go deeply to
become a thinker about ethical issues
okay thanks number two hi Gershon
deublin from MIT from Media Lab I so one
of the last things you said was we need
systems that make us feel smart and I
wondered if you could comment on this
question of kind of how long it should
take to learn to use the systems how
easy should they be and then I asked
that because I mean teamwork as an
example is not something that is
necessarily something we're well-suited
for at the outset we learned to work
together over a long periods of time and
as we build these AI systems what if it
takes two years to learn how to work
with them or how should we kind of think
about that question
okay so first one systems in general
I'll just quote Don Norman who said for
those of you not in HCI a really
important aged person in the HCI
community he said I don't need a manual
T to use my toaster of course that might
not be true anymore so I think if we so
it's true that as people we need to
learn with respect to each team
work with those team members I think it
should take no longer to learn how to
work with the team computer agents than
it takes to learn with each other and
that depends on the people and whether
they've actually how much they've been
parts of teams before or not but the
systems I think we should designed to be
the best of team players thanks the last
two questions have been from Cambridge
and in continuing that trend I think
Christian number three is from Cambridge
as well no more Cambridge questions
after this hi other Cambridge David
Karger MIT David hi and I guess alumnus
of year 1988 AI class so you talked
about these sort of foundational
principles of collaboration your your
theory of collaboration and such and it
struck me is interesting because you
talked about sort of the need for
consensus around goals and shared plans
and things one of your colleagues
might've student did some really
interesting work a few years ago on
communication with aliens and sort of
developed a theory about how you could
actually carry out communication and say
the communication was coming at what was
happening even when the two parties had
no shared no shared goals no no shared
understanding of the the universe and
I'm wondering whether that sort of you
know how that relates to your arguments
that you have to have these these
consensus goals and bringing it closer
to home
think about user studies where our
subjects are often not aware of what
they're doing or even deceived about
what their goals are how does that play
into what you were talking about so
remember what I said is if the
principles are violated you don't have
real teamwork so is the answer with ma
do is to do it justice is much longer
but he and I asked actually disagree on
when you have communication and dialogue
so and I would have to look at the user
studies to give you a particular answer
but it's not saying you can have things
that look like team work happen
accidentally but if you don't have
these conditions I can take that group
of people and whatever they're trying to
do and give you an example where it
would fall apart and they would fail so
that's the point of the principles it's
not that you can't like you can have a
system that looks like it's that's
remember my point about errors you can
have a system that looks like it's smart
until it looks like it's really done so
you can have something that looks like
it's working like teamwork and then it
falls apart I can give you an example
from the 1990s at Harvard I love this
example women basketball the Ivy League
always sends one team to the NCAA's
Harvard went first
their first match was with Stanford
because they were at the bottom and
Stanford was at the time Stanford's best
player I don't know tore her ACL or
something Harvard won the game and it
was played at Stanford why because they
had teamwork asked their coach they
could Harvard could lose their best
player Stanford couldn't okay let's take
one last question here number two I'm
Melanie Mitchell
Portland State University hey hey I
you made the really great suggestion
that products that have AI in them like
the Barbie example should advertise
their limitations but I'm wondering if
you can comment a little bit more on how
feasible that actually is given that
many of the systems that seem to be the
most successful are the hardest to
understand so I'd like to make it so so
first let me say that a system knowing
its own limits is one of the hardest
problems I know of with respect to the
Barbie doll I'd like to get to the first
step of not being deceptive about the
capabilities that a system has and the
designers know so I didn't say this with
Barbie but it's one of my quips about it
most of us have known three-year-olds I
don't know a single three-year-old
who follows a script I mean there's
anybody if you do raise your hand
because I want to talk to you I know a
lot of parents who would like to know
how
this happened they always okay we don't
follow scripts that's why some of these
chat BOTS have trouble so I would just
like them to say look this is a cute
it's not you know for a normal kid in a
healthy environment with great parents
it probably doesn't matter the kid will
throw it away after two days I would
like to start with not exaggerating the
capabilities okay
let's thank Barbara again for her
stimulating talk and she'll be around
for the next few days
[Applause]
you